from the I didn't watch that you
shouldn't watch that I don't care
which Network it's on you should
not watch the GOP
debates you shouldn't you shouldn't
watch that there there's no
relevancy in watching that
debate you want to know why do you want
to know why there's no relevancy and you
really don't have to watch I mean you
want to want you want to know what
they're saying but it's all the same old
it's all the same everyone
went and voted against yester or on
Tuesday that's what it is they're
doubling down the same that people
went and voted against and said no we do
not want that stuff the Republican party
like yeah you do you just don't get it
yet let me let me let me have a
let me spend all this money having a
debate for us to all to stand on stage
and the guy who's gonna be the nominee
isn't on stage because he's a ass
and he's got to go hold some
rally to try to prove a point
some kind of Dick
contest and he Rambles on and on and on
he doesn't know who Kim jung-un is he
knew who the leader of hungry is
or where hungry's at he just might be
hungry that's it I don't know Jesus
Christ are you kidding me why
shouldn't you watch this there's a
million reasons why you shouldn't watch
this
trash but the main reason is is that
Tuesday this week this week on Tuesday
there was an actual poll like a real
poll not the stupid
polls they keep trying to sell us in the
media a real pole that was taken in Ohio
in Virginia in Pennsylvania in Kentucky
real polls all around the
country and they told Republicans to get
hey hey your policies Republicans
you can get that's what they said
that's what the polls said literally
that I mean you
know it's what it should the poll should
be is how do you feel about Republican
policies eh
man get and they chose that
one oh these guys these some